bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
federica bonjour j mee bonjour mygale
marie-luce bonjour secrétaire national
de bâtir le pays martinique ce parti
politique qui a fait ça à sa rentrée
c'est de saison d'ailleurs il y a
quelques jours donc vous avez fait votre
votre rentrée
alors dans un contexte particulier
puisque il ya un peu plus d'un an
maintenant
pierre pierre samot a laissé les
commandes donc du parti bâtir ainsi que
la ville
quelques temps après le lamantin donc à
laisser les commandes à david zobda
pierre samot donc qui a quitté la
présidence du parti les présidents
d'honneur de bâtir mais après plus de
vingt ans quand même un à la tête parti
qui l'a qu'il a fondé donc voilà il ya
ce contexte particulier du coup est ce
que vous êtes fin prêt pour affronter
donc les élections municipales de mars
prochain
mygales marius effectivement nous sommes
fin prêts je dois dire que nous
n'arrivons pas là comme un cheveux donc
cela sous peu nous avons été donc à la
bonne école avec pied aux symboles
durant de nombreuses années nous avons
de l'expérience me super samus est un
site un grand homme et il avait une
autre écoute une clé steam est
aujourd'hui david zobda ayant pris le
relais il n'ya pour nous donc aucun
souci tant au niveau de la gestion de
bâtir le pays martinique qu'au niveau
même de la vie rudimentaire
alors justement est-ce que du coup ce
changement à la direction même du du
parti fait que le parti se renouvellent
quelque part lui aussi
dans ces instances dirigeantes mais
également dans sa composition générale
quoi voilà effectivement le parti de
l'eau du congrès d'avril 2010 huit
cimetières samui a démissionné de son
poste de président et david jobin a pris
le relais moi même qui était trésorier
depuis une dizaine d'années est devenu
secrétaire geithner de bâtir le pays
martinique
nous avons effectivement rage unis donc
ce comité national parce que vous savez
donc bon on a tendance à dire que les
parents qui vieillissent bien nous à
bâtir nous avons passé dans que ce parti
politique insiste d'avenir et
aujourd'hui à bâtir le pays martinique
les personnes donc qui composent donc ce
parti politique ont conscience du
travail qui nous reste à faire même si
jadis ce qui a été fait a été a été bon
mais je crois que nous sommes sous une
majorité sur une bonne base de rampe de
lancement et aujourd'hui je crois que
connaissant toutes les directives qu'il
y ait de bâtir avec son nouveau
président mais aussi avec pierre samot
qui en est le président d'honneur et
bien nous constituons donc une bonne
équipe et que d'ailleurs j'en ai pour
preuve dimanche l'eau de la santé
général et de la rentrée politique
vous avez pu constater que bâtir est
vraiment donc ce nouvel erp et que nous
allons tout faire pour que nous transmet
mais les présidents ne soit pas d'issue
donc de nous d'accord donc
renouvellement certain rajeunissement à
l'ordre du jour est le principal défi
pour vous pour notamment ces élections
municipales sera de de conserver
donc la municipalité du lamentin david
zobda et mer actuellement mais il a
succédé à pierre samot il n'a pas été
élus en 2014 il était sur la liste était
son premier adjoint
donc effectivement mais la voilà donc
qui là il va faire l'élection à la tête
de la liste est donc c'est quand même un
challenge
oui c'est effectivement c'est un très
beau challenge mais je dois rappeler que
david zobda ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il va dans une élection des
élections cantonales
de 2006 à 2008 il avait brillamment été
élu sur un coton qui avait jusque là et
il est une des tenues par une fois
collectée au dîner offert david zobda
elle a l'occasion de confirmer tout me
direz son ancrage donc de l'amandinois
et de prouver que le fauteuil de maire
que lui à l'itie pierre sambou un
nouveau 2018 n'était pas une
circonstance un événement bien au
contraire je crois que aujourd'hui donc
david jobin a toutes les capacités il a
occupé de deux grandes fonctions au sein
je prends l'exemple du conseil du
conseil général un dojo d'ici là et il
il en a été le premier vice président
avec toute l'expérience qu'il a aux
côtés de pierre samot aussi dans le but
de bien et est quand même premier
adjoint durant de nombreuses années et
pour nous aujourd'hui les élections
municipales ce sera donc une
transformation de l'essai et que je
crois l'homme mériterait bien donc sa
place
alors la ville du lamentin chi chi un
peu l'impression un peu à la croisée de
de son chemin de développement
économique bon c'est vrai que c'est le
poumon économique industriel de lamarthe
hic depuis déjà maintenant plusieurs
années et donc là l'impression que voilà
que c'est la ville est un peu à la
croisée de des chemins de son
développement par moments qui peut même
à voir certains aspects peut-être
anarchique où est donc voilà est-ce que
vous entendez proposer une nouvelle ère
également pour le lamentin avec ce
contexte justement de renouvellement et
de rajeunissement effectivement l'aude
de notre corps rentrée politique de
dimanche dernier le président de bâtir
est elle donc là très clairement rappelé
au niveau même de la ville puisque
aujourd'hui nous faisons pas anti de que
de la communauté d'agglo de la cacem ce
qui est bon entre guillemets que nous
prive de levier financier pour pouvoir
développer donc bon comme on l'aurait
souhaité notre ville mais des rues de là
clairement rappelé est donc à trouver
des outils que nous avons déjà mis en
place je vais parler du projet de ville
numéro 2
j'ai parlé donc du plus ce sont les
outils qui nous permettent de travailler
et déjà donc d'avoir de de perspective
nouvelle donc pour le développement
économique en inde de nombreuses villes
de par nous-mêmes de principe à l'issue
d'un maintien mais aussi donc sur
d'autres leviers donc il a beaucoup
parlé de justice sociale je crois que
aujourd'hui il faut aussi donc en tenu
compte que nous avons une population en
quelque part qui souffrent et que la de
notre nouvelle mandature ce soit donc un
sacré programme donc pour ramener plus
d'un peu de justice sociale très bien
donc nous verrons ce que ce que donnera
donc cette élection effectivement
municipal au lamentin ou quand même ben
hatira a cédé un peu de terrain tout de
même au cours des derniers scrutins on
s'en est rendu compte il ya une
opposition qui s'est vraiment des
oppositions mêmes qui se sont constitués
au lamentin donc nous verrons tous à la
question aussi pour bâtir le pays
martinique
c'est justement après les municipales et
territoriales qui sont déjà là en
perspective qui se prépare d'ores et
déjà dans les états majors politiques et
justement est-ce que l'alliance avec
notamment le ppm au sein d'un ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle et toujours
aussi prégnant solide est ce que c'est
toujours d'actualité
je dis pas qu'on va dire comme vous
l'avez dit donc vous me disiez que vous
avez constaté que en termes de voix nous
perdions et bien c'est bien pour cette
raison que nous allons mettre tout notre
énergie est donc sur ces élections
municipales nous allons donc
d'ailleurs nous avons déjà commencé
pendant c'est un nombre d'actions de
proximité et ça porte ses fruits
nous allons faire en sorte que la
population s'approprie à nouveau mais de
manière donc globale donc je parle oui
oui oui oui c'est pousser pour revenir
c'est pour ses manières vous dire que
nous nous trouvons ces voix ne trouve
notre horizon tout cas si des élections
ne sais pas mais nous sommes nous sommes
nous faisons partie d'une alliance et
d'une à dire ce n'est pas le pépin nous
a dit le pm non nous sommes dans une
alliance qui a plusieurs partis et
mouvements politiques et bien plus que
jamais nous y sommes
en 13 ans à se réduire un petit peu
essentiellement à bâtir et il ya une
convention il ya une convention qui est
un moyen moyenne convention et il y
avait neuf parties et neuf partis et
mouvements et il ya quand même deux
parties qui se sont excusés par ce
qu'ils avaient prévu des réunions se
joue la note bien au contraire j'ai j'ai
pas eu cette impression bien au
contraire l'alliance fonctionne la
non-sanction bâtir donc y intégrer batik
participe donc aux réunions que font
donc à toute sa place dans un équilibre
entre les we will marteen l'avouer nous
l'avons dit comme d'autres partis donc
l'a dit donc l'alliance est pas un parti
politique l'alliance est un ensemble de
partis et toutes et tous les partis tous
les mouvements donc ont leur mot à dire
et c'est ça qui fait qu'il faut faire la
force de venir square a pas de remise en
question pas de recul par rapport à ça
pas de on sait déjà décidées au nom de
ceux qui ont qui ont pris donc du recul
je parle donc de naissains présent pour
ceux qui sont là et ceux qui sont à soi
il soyez en sûr ils sont déterminés à ce
que l'alliance plus poursuivre sa route
voilà alors on va devoir conclure mygale
marie-luce secrétaire national de bâtir
le pays martinique qui réfléchit enfin
collectivement un certain nombre de
commandes y reste deux défis sociétaux
euros pour la martinique est par exemple
la jeu
vous avez vous organisé des séances
d'information grand public le mardi
il ya quelques mois par exemple le thème
c'était conséquences économiques et
sociales du vieillissement de la
population des filles opportunité pour
le pays martinique avait que deux
experts qui étaient invités pour prendre
débattre voilà ça fait partie de la vie
du parti
ça viendra certainement ce sera diffusé
au cours de vos campagnes électorales
tout ça oui oui bien sûr nous avons oui
c'est ça ce sont des axes que nous avons
développée donc l'eau du congrès donc
les mardis de bâtir donc nous avons
aussi une lettre pour l'humilité la
population mais nous avons aussi donc
les comités de quartier et je puis vous
dire que la population comme je vous le
disais précédemment donc s'approprie de
cela est que nous avons l'intention de
d'amplifier donc ces actions de
proximité et des formations au niveau du
grand public lorsque je veux dire c'est
que est ce que ça montre que vous avez
vocation à vous étendre maintenant sur
toute la martinique parce qu'on
al'impression de bâtir ça s'appelle
bâtir le pays martinique mais que
finalement le parti n'est influent que
sur le lamantin quoique ça se réduit où
ça se résume à la politique municipale
au lamentin même si on le rappelle david
zobda et à la collectivité territoriale
de martinique
d'autres vous avez une députée dans vos
rangs josette manin etc voilà
territorialement vous n'arrivez pas à
vous détendre sur l'île au fait quand on
fait partie d'une alliance se dissipe un
peu plus compliqué parce que dans que
l'alliance ce n'est pas une alliance
martinois béthune dernière ce qui est
sûr toute la martinique
donc c'est quand même complexe ils ont
même fait attention gêné aux entournures
cette alliance un petit peu de temps
votre effort non pas du tout n'ayant pas
d'enfant ou non non je crois qu'il ne
faut pas courir plusieurs lièvres à la
fois et les choses donc si bâti doit
s'implanter dans d'autres communes et
bien donc ça se fait râler mais en tout
cas pour l'instant nous sommes dans une
deuxième volet tic vous n'avez pas une
main sur la tête qui vous empêche de ne
pas regarder l'horizon bien loin on en
aura du tout pas du tout non pas du tout
soyons rassurés donc baptiste une partie
majeure il y en a peut-être qui verrait
mal votre développement
non mais c'est mal mais non pas nous pas
du tout parce que d'autres poissons est
parti parle tout avoir tout sur géo
l'île dont vous avez quand même cet
objectif cette ambition se faire ça va
ça va ça va se faire
merci merci mygale marie-luce bonne
journée à toutes et à tous merci merci
[Musique]